in general we would expect our asset
manager to have the following features
first off loaded assets should be cached
so that multiple requests won't trigger
reloads of content but instead use the
in-memory version we should also be able
to receive asynchronous notification
when an asset has been loaded this
allows us to go ahead and load the asset
while also rendering the game scene at
the same time in addition we should
allow batches of assets to be loaded in
a single call this is very critical for
when we do map loading or other
heterogeneous file computation where we
need to pass images JSON files and
sounds into the system to allow them to
load in a single call